thank you for joining
and welcome to our session on file
storage for high performance workloads
i'm alone and i'm joined today by jill
from our google silicon
team and we'll be presenting to you
file usage for high performance
workloads
before i begin a little bit about myself
my name is dr alan cohen i'm a 15-year
veteran
of the enterprise storage industry and i
recently joined google
through the acquisition of elastifile
elastophile developed the technology
that is at the base of many of the new
capabilities
that we'll be presenting to you today
so let's dive right in
file storage essentially powers many
high performance workloads in google
cloud
and throughout the industries whether
it's rendering of the latest
blockbuster movies discovery and life
sciences
including drug discovery for dealing
with the latest pandemics
or any such industries such as silicon
and eda but the truth of the matter
is that file architectures
are not a one size fit all technology
essentially if you have a small workload
you can use a local file system that
provides you access to one vm
accessing that data but as you grow your
systems and want to share more data
shared file systems allow you to
essentially
connect multiple vms or containers
to a single file system through
simplified
interfaces and protocols such as nfs
but as your needs grow and adds you need
more and more compute power it is not
just
enough to scale compute you also need to
scale the back end
file system to support those demanding
workloads
and that's where you need scalable file
systems which also come in two
flavors parallel file systems
allow you to connect using plugins on
the client side
to multiple back-end storage nodes
while scale out file systems essentially
retain the simplicity of shared file
systems
allowing you to connect through
protocols such as nfs
while at the same time assuring that the
storage
at the back end can also scale
and match the performance requirements
of your front-end systems
but moving hpc workloads to cloud
is not just about performance there is
a collection of features that you
require
to easily migrate your workloads into
the cloud
beyond the high capacity and high
performance
you want the elasticity to grow and
shrink
on demand to really benefit from what
the cloud provides
you want to retain the simplicity of
your local file system and the way
you use your scale out file systems
within your environments
you want to be able to provision on
demand
you want to be able to integrate with
cloud schedulers
so that you do not need to manually
manage the environment
and you want that file system to
maintain
natively all of the attributes of the
file systems
such as locking and that you used
within your on-prem environment
that is the reason that we are
excited to introduce to you file store
high scale
file store high scale is a new tier
of google's file store product that is
essentially
a managed elastic scale out file service
that is designed to match the
requirements
of hpc and htc
workloads with file store high scale
we are extending the capacities of the
file store you're used to
to capacities of up to
320 terabytes we are
supporting a background scale out
architecture
we are allowing you now to both row and
shrink your environments for high scale
instances
and we expand the performance of file
store to
over 16 gigabytes per second
or more than tenfold of our previous
capabilities
in terms of iops you can now reach
hundreds of thousands
of iops and even more so and more
importantly
for hpc environments you can now
connect thousands of
front-end machines to the back-end
storage
with these new capabilities essentially
file store enables you to migrate
your workloads into the cloud you can
now
run all types of hpc workload
with a native nfs file system
inside the cloud connect to it using
either vms or containers
and we'll even demonstrate to you
shortly that you can use
preemptable vms and save considerable
costs on your compute side storage
you can now support life sciences
workloads
manufacturing finance and
more to demonstrate to you how
such a file system is used in production
i'm going to turn it over to jill to
present to us how they use this
technology
for their eda workload
thank you alan hi everybody i'm jill
i've been lucky to have been able to
implement world-class networking
cpu gpus and mobile resources at
different companies
i've also been into the software
industry supporting
enterprise and personal batch queuing
software
and now for two and a half years i've
been at google
implementing world-class silicon our
application
our needs are those of a typical hpc eda
customer
we rely on a lot of third-party
commercial software
that we assembled into flows each one
with hundreds of steps
our users use mix of interactive tool
sessions
and also batch workloads across
thousands of machines
they share their data by using large
data files that they want to share with
their colleagues
and our application is not a web
application
we cannot afford to lose a single job
otherwise it may hit
the schedule up to two weeks for example
finally we operate worldwide in multiple
continents
our initial assessment of filestore in
2018 before we took that journey was
it looked good that it was simple to
instantiate
it was compatible with terraform so we
could use infrastructure as code
it was managed so we didn't have to
spend time watching how is the machine
performing
somebody else was guaranteeing it that
we were using 20 terabyte machines and
file store offered up to 64 terabytes so
that was great
and it also grows online so we could
start with small machine and add more
capacity as needed
the problems we identified were was the
file system a
server file system or desktop file
system and in the end it's managed so we
don't care about those implementation
details
the big one which was initially
throttling us was there were no user or
three quotas
so how do we make this work we decided
to allocate
one per user and finally
we identified that it was just a nice to
have to have the feature of reducing
online
our cloud architecture is based on using
one cloud project
per chip each user gets a
virtual desktop into the cloud which is
basically a red hat 7
machine inside your web browser those
can be quite large with 96 cpus and 2
terabyte of rams
all the design files are stored on the
nfs file store server we allocate at
least one per user
and we rely on auto mount to enable
collaborations
so that each person can see other users
file
and finally we deploy the batch queuing
system so that we can maximize license
usage
and the machines in the farm automount
the needed data from file stores
so how did it go we started
back in 2017 with 50 gig machine
and file stores turned out to be easy
reliable and skilled
we went in production with a better
service we started with a dozen
file stores and we ended up growing way
past our plans and expectation
so we have to say thanks to the cloud
for delivering to us
unlimited and instant capacity we ended
up reaching
close to 500 file store servers totaling
4.2 petabyte capacity worldwide
and so despite having 500 file servers
it was
easy to manage between terraform and the
management of file store
it was great it was also very reliable
we never lost a single
byte despite having 4.2 petabytes
we had a couple of incidents and they
were mostly related to performance or
temporarily
unavailable data with for a few hours
the great thing that we discovered with
file stores
is you all know what is the typical
sysadmin duty
a system administrator has to ensure
that one user cannot bring down
other users by abusing the systems and
so at other companies with a traditional
file server appliance i've personally
experienced the overload of a file
server
when an hpc application decrys deploys
across thousands of cores
so it's very difficult to identify where
the load is coming from
the nfs protocol has no quality of
service built in
so file store gave us the i o quality of
service we did not know we needed
it solved by construction but overload
there was
no way a single user could impact the
work of
other users
and finally performance file store
was able to provide enough i o and
capacity
for most of our application only the
statics
timing sign off which runs across
hundreds of corners
was too much for one file store so we
mitigated this performance bottleneck
by manually sharding the rods across
multiple file store per user
now we are currently exploring file
store high scale
and our users are reporting that they
are liking shared right
the fact that it can size higher than 64
terabyte
and that some workloads are running way
faster
than uh on a single file store now back
to you ellen
thank you jill so with that we would
like to actually demo the system to you
and its new capabilities we're going to
simulate an hpc workload using a file
store high scale
instance we're going to automate
that using slurm and then we're going to
spin up
thousands of preemptable vms connect
them to the backend file store system
and demonstrate to you some of the
supported performance
the first step is of course launching a
file store
instance that is very simple done
through the cloud
the cloud console and essentially it
runs in a very similar way
to the way you're used to launching file
store instances
so far but we added that capability of
launching high scale
instances allowing you to launch them
with
up to 320 terabytes
of storage in the single file systems
you can select the region and the zone
where you want to launch
you can select the network that you want
to use
and even control access using certain
ips
you name your file share let's do next
2020
and just press create
this is a fully managed system so the
scale out file system is being launched
for us
at the back end and once it's ready
we simply have an ip that we can start
mounting clients to we'll do that now
with slurm for orchestration launching
thousands of preemptable vms
back in cloud console we can see that
those vms
are launching and at the same time
slurm is now initiating jobs within
each of those clients and those jobs
connect to the file store high scale
instance
at the back end these are all
preemptable
vms so slurm can launch them
while saving over 80 percent
of the costs in terms of the compute
for the systems that you are using
at the top portion of this screen you
see the number of connections
and the throughput that is being
generated by these workloads
as they run these jobs you can see that
we are now
already at about 2000 connections to our
back end file store high scale instance
and you can also see that our throughput
is reaching 25 gigabytes
per second allowing all of these clients
to run in parallel now because these
clients are running on preemptable vms
it may occur and at this number it
definitely does occur
that some of these vms will actually be
preempted but that is not an
issue for this architecture because
our orchestration system will
essentially just spin
up these vms again to complete the jobs
that they were running
all of the data is persisted in file
store high scale at the back end
so the data is not lost even though
our vm has been preempted
so as you can see now slurm is
relaunching vms and making sure
that our whole job process has completed
and that is the tail of completion that
you see
at the back of this run
so what we we demonstrate here
essentially
we launched a 320 terabyte scale out
file system
at the back end with a series of clicks
from cloud
console
we made sure that we can run preemptable
vms
and launched in this case 2000
preemptable vms
against this single scale out file
system
there is no overhead because with this
orchestration you can essentially launch
the vms when you need them
and when they're no longer needed you
simply spin them down
everything is persistent on the file
system
and even the file system itself you can
scale
up and scale down on demand
per your needs we connected thousands of
vms in parallel
we showed over well over actually 16
gigabytes per second of throughput
and we completed 100
of our processing and all of the data
was persisted in our backend file system
if you would like to learn more about
file store and its new capabilities
you can check them out in the links
provided in this slide but the proof of
the pudding
is in the eating so we welcome you to go
to cloud console
launch a file store high scale instance
and test your own workloads to see the
performance
that you achieve
with that i'd like to thank jill again
for joining me
thank you all for being here and we look
forward to receiving your
questions and getting your feedback and
usage of the system
thank you